[Musik]
ich bin nicole ich bin max essig bettina
ich bin daniel ich bin älter ich bin
krank ich bin alice ich bin sicher ich
bin nicole ich bin jörg ich bin hat ja
ich bin als ich bin dennis ich bin
ursula ich bin guido ich bin richtig
billig denn iris und ich bin solo
selbstständig seit mitte märz sind mir
annähernd 100 prozent meine einnahmen
durch corona weggebrochen
über eine million solo selbstständige
setzen derzeit zu hause ohne einkommen
für uns solo selbstständige gibt es
staatliche hilfen die wir aber nicht für
unsere lebensunterhalt verwenden dürfen
solange zum schutz der bevölkerung
darauf verzichtet wird festivals
konzerte kongresse messen oder von
veranstaltungen durchzuführen steht die
gesamte veranstaltungswirtschaft nahezu
still
somit stehen viele tausend solo
selbstständige in den nächsten monaten
vor der privatinsolvenz das aktuelle
konjunkturpaket vom vierten juni 2020
berücksichtigt unsere branche nicht
wir sind eventmanager
veranstaltungstechniker künstler
toningenieure agenturen regisseure
zauberer musiker dekorateure
schauspielerin und viele viele mehr so
lange die maßnahmen zur eindämmung der
pandemie nötig sind brauchen wir
funktionieren der unterstützung zur
ernährung unserer familien
zum erhalt unserer selbständigkeit und
zukunftsfähigkeit
deshalb brauchen wir jetzt antworten wie
es mit uns weitergehen soll und fordern
die politik auf mit uns in den
dringenden und wichtigen dialog zu
treten
wir alle wollen nach der krise wieder
festivals konzerte und veranstaltungen
jeglicher art gemeinsam erleben dürfen
wir haben angst vor der zukunft
die veranstaltungsbranche liegt brach
die private kulturszene auch davon
betroffen sind vor allem selbstständige
die auf und hinter der bühne beschäftigt
sind
die meisten von ihnen haben keine eigene
mitarbeiter deshalb heißen sie solo
selbstständige in deutschland gibt es
über zwei millionen solo selbständige
zum vergleich in der autobranche
arbeiten noch nicht einmal 900 tausend
beschäftigte solo selbständige sind also
eine richtig große gruppe in der
gesellschaft sie arbeiten in allen
möglichen branchen solo selbstständige
sind zb it-berater unternehmens
beraterinnen grafiker dozentinnen
klempner kosmetikerinnen und künstler
manche kommen mit der korona krise klar
andere stehen seit märz vor dem abgrund
der vorwurf steht im raum die politik
lässt die solo selbstständigen im stich
sie sollen sich allein durch die krise
kämpfen
allein in nordrhein westfalen leben
350.000 solo selbständige uns erreichte
der anruf einer kölner kabarettistin es
war ein hilferuf sie habe keine aufträge
mehr für die inanspruchnahme der
soforthilfe des bundes sei sie nicht
berechtigt die überbrückungshilfe des
landes reiche hinten und vorne nicht
wir treffen uns mit ihr und anderen
comedians in einem kölner kulturhaus dem
stolberg wissen sie was mich wirklich
wundert in jeder straßenbahn in jedem
bus in jedem flugzeug darf jeder platz
besetzt seien im theater aber nicht es
wird irgendwie so getan als sei kultur
in corona seiten der risikofaktor
schlechthin war ja wahrscheinlich war
lachen ansteckend ist
sie verstehen wegen ansteckend auch
kommen sich waren halt ist ja allein zu
hause ich freue mich über jedes spiel
hat mir noch ein nein natürlich wird
immer gesagt im flugzeug zum beispiel
darf jeder platz besetzt sein weil die
luft da so sauber ist wie in einem op
saal
ja genau wie in einem op saal in dem 300
leute um den tisch stehen ihm ein wer
von ihnen ist nicht schon ins flugzeug
gestiegen hat sich gedacht endlich mal
drei stunden tief durchatmen ist doch
albern
nein die luftfahrtindustrie hat einfach
nur gute lobby in corona zeiten blüht
der lobbyismus auf ohne ende
gucken sie mal allein die lufthansa hat
neun milliarden euro staatshilfen
bekommen die firma ist nicht mal vier
milliarden wert für die
rüstungsindustrie gab es bisher zehn
milliarden euro an staatshilfen mir wenn
nicht aufgefallen dass es weniger kriege
gab und für die komplette kulturszene in
deutschland gab es bisher eine milliarde
da sieht man wie die interessen verteilt
sind an dieser stelle ein kleiner
hinweis in eigener sache beziehungsweise
in sachen aller solo selbständiger wir
haben ja auch diesen 9000 euro
soforthilfe bekommen durften die aber
quasi nicht ausgeben also wir durften
davon weder unsere miete bezahlen doch
unsere krankenversicherung noch was zu
essen kaufen die waren nur für
betriebsausgaben also leasingrate fürs
auto büromiete et cetera ausgaben die
kaum ein solo selbstständige hat und
selbst wenn von der bezahlten büromiete
kann man nicht leben
ich weiß der eine oder andere von ihnen
denkt sich jetzt auch kommen die
hartmann die habe ich bei ladies night
im fernsehen gesehen habe ich im radio
gehört hat doch geld verdient konnte
jedoch davon ihre miete bezahlen
da muss ich sagen leider verloren das
wäre zwar logisch ich hab das ja anfangs
auch geglaubt aber wir durften dann
erfahren dass jeder cent den wir trotz
corona bedingten auftrittsverbot
verdient haben
von den 9000 euro abgezogen wird das
heißt wir durften liga von dieser
soforthilfe noch von unserem eigenen
verdienten geld unsere miete bezahlen
ich weiß so kann man nicht überleben nur
weigern sich die zuständigen politiker
das einzusehen allen voran ist dick im
geschäft altmaier und senja
schlaftablette scholz der
kanzlerkandidat der ist belebt was
würden die laster und ich sag mal so es
würde doch jedes grundschulkind
verstehen
ich gehe schritt weiter jedes
vorschulkind würde es verstehen wenn man
einem vorschulkind sagen würde
hier hast du dein taschengeld davon das
tier aber keine kekse kaufen und jetzt
auf geld von der oma davon das sind ja
auch keine kekse kaufen und jetzt geht's
los und kauft ja paar kekse würde jedes
vorschulkind sagen seiner tante bis so
doof das geht doch gar nicht
und wenn unsere politiker nicht mal halb
so klug sind die vorschulkinder sollten
uns vielleicht ein paar neue besorgen
es kam corona und was kam dann das große
loch das große loch also erst war so ein
bisschen
mal gucken was jetzt passiert wie lange
das dauert und so kurz die illusion das
ist vielleicht ab den osterferien oder
so irgendwann wieder weiter geht und
dann irgendwann das bewusstsein dass es
damit nicht herrn sein wird und dann kam
ein schwarzes loch und viel arbeit viel
kampf viel psychostress er erst machen
wir das das große los gezogen dass man
auch in der gleichen branche arbeitet
das heißt wir hatten halt von 1 wohl
auch so selbstständig hat eine
künstlerin agentur
die agenturen werden ja in dem ganzen
wust ganz oft vergessen
wobei ohne diesen das bindeglied
zwischen den theatern und den künstlern
und künstlerinnen und so waren wir halt
beide betroffen und das ist schon echt
ein hammer wenn man so von 1000 anderen
erfährt so ihr beide hat übrigens ab
jetzt kein einkommen mehr
das ist schon ein schlag ins kontor
und dann kam mir irgendwann dieses mit
diesen 9000 euro soforthilfe also haben
wir das dann natürlich in diesem glauben
auch beantragt weil uns ja umsatz ohne
ende weggebrochen ist und als wir den
antrag abgegeben hatte wurde sowas dann
in einer nacht und nebelaktion von der
website gelöscht also ohne irgendeine
offizielle erklärung oder ankündigung
das regt mich wahnsinnig auf wir haben
normalerweise in deutschland ein
grundsatz der rechtssicherheit und für
uns wird das alles ausgehebelt gab es
außer diesen 9000 euro noch weitere
unterstützung
es gab dann von diesen 9000 euro
nachträglich im juni beschlossen dass
wir davon in nrw das ist ja jedem
bundesland anders 2000 euro für privaten
lebensunterhalt behalten durften und ist
das dann sicher oder kommt dann doch
wieder irgendwo andere all das haben wir
uns auch gefragt aber bisher gab es
keine gegenteilige meldung und es gab
für juni juli august noch mal 1000 euro
pro monat für private lebenshaltungen
nrw also das scheint sicher zu sein dass
wir das geld behalten dürfen gab es
sonst noch irgendwelche unterschiedlich
ja es gab doch dieses großzügige angebot
des sozial schutzpaket sozialschutz
paket heißt es wurde uns dieses
wahnsinnig große angebot unterbreitet
dass wir kulturschaffenden und alle solo
selbstständigen doch für die privaten
lebenshaltungskosten hartz 4 beantragen
dürfen da wir waren weder arbeitslos
noch beschäftigungslos insofern passt
der antrag schon mal gar nicht müssten
sie an ihre ersparnisse daran ja klar
die sind wir haben wahnsinnig viel von
unseren ersparnissen ausgegeben und
gleichzeitig weiß es ist ja nicht nur
das geld wir sind ja nicht alle so
selbständig wie wahnsinnig geil drauf
sind nicht abgesichert zu leben wir sind
alle so selbstständig weil das unser
traumberuf ist weil das keine beruf ist
sondern eine berufung deswegen machen
wir das ja wir machen das ja nicht weil
das so geil ist dass man weiß es gibt
kein soziales netz für uns sondern wir
haben uns alle bewusst dafür entschieden
dass das einberufung ist das liegt uns
am herzen und das war ja nicht mehr das
geld wir dürfen wir unsere berufung
nicht mehr nachgehen wie fühlen sie sich
ja scheiße wie soll man sich dabei
fühlen scheiße im stich gelassen und
wütend und ich bin auch nachhaltig
wütend
[Musik]
wie begann dieses jahr das jahr begann
sehr gut und es sah nach einem wirklich
guten jahr aus also ich kam anfangen ein
mitte januar kam ich aus der schweiz
zurück
von einem hervorragenden ganz tollen
menschlich wie musikalisch ganz tollen
engagement und hatte zwei stücke hier in
deutschland die vereinzelt in
verschiedenen theatern gespielt wurden
und ich hatte einen unterschriebenen
vertrag bei national bekannten
sommerfestspielen von mai bis august an
ganz ordentlich bezahlten vertrag der
dann aber leider zwei wochen vor beginn
zwei wochen vor beginn wurde der
gekündigt mit der begründung dass die
krone bedingten maßnahmen des landes
niedersachsen kleine durchführung der
festspiele zu lassen ohne ersatz ohne
endzone sich nicht einig sind
nichts da hat sich auch niemand bei mir
gemeldet dass da jemand das irgendwie
ersetzen will weder von den festspielen
eigentlich noch vom land niedersachsen
oder was für mich vielleicht zuständig
werde vom land nrw fühlen sich im stich
gelassen von den behörden
ja ja das muss man so sagen also vor
allen dingen was diese diese soforthilfe
von 9000 euro betrifft die einfach an
den bedürfnissen und an der realität der
solo selbständige künstler vorbei geht
einfach die solo selbstständigen die
kleine betriebsausgaben haben selbst die
die welche haben müssen ja essen
die können ja nicht nur ihre
betriebsausgaben zahlen und man sagt
dann super die haben doch geld bekommen
die müsste dann ihre miete bezahlen die
müssen ihre lager kosten bezahlen und
wovon sollen sie leben gibt es vom staat
irgendeine beratungsstelle irgendjemand
mit dem die reden können eine
beratungsstelle und sich kann man nicht
sagen also man hat einfach auch
festgestellt dass die vertreter aus der
politik haben wir so gar keine ahnung
hatten was was die leute dort bewegt
eben die politik sagt ja immer gerne die
krise als chance sehen oder warum werden
die kreativen nicht kreativ jetzt und so
aber man muss da einfach
es bleiben ein sänger ein musical
darsteller kann nicht plötzlich anfangen
irgendwelche kunst filme zu drehen oder
roman zu schreiben oder so die
kreativität die ist in der regel bei den
menschen die das seit 30 jahren auf der
bühne machen doch auch auf diesem
bereich beschränkt die werden alle vor
der pleite stehen bestehen eine volle
pleite schon so sieht es aus und die
zeit scheint stillzustehen als johannas
maske fällt der momentan die wahrheit
und entblößt eine verlogene welt
ja ich glaube eines der großen probleme
ist dass es so unterschiedliche
behandlungen gibt der unterschiedlichen
industriezweigen zum beispiel ich hab
mal zwei beispiele mitgebracht und zwar
das ist die bayern-bank der offiziellen
beim ersten spieltag und das ist mein
erster spieltag
und ich glaube dass daraus was spricht
nämlich dass die kultur geopfert werden
soll dass wir in anderen
wirtschaftszweigen wieder normal leben
können und das ist das was ich
kritisiere bei viele denken ja die
kultur das ist ja so nischenprodukte
aber wenn man sich die zahlen anguckt
dann ist was ganz anderes nämlich spiele
der ersten zweiten und dritten liga
haben im jahr 2017 2018 etwa 21
millionen menschen besucht aber im
gleichen jahr waren 34 millionen
menschen im theater und 114 millionen
waren im museum ja und auch von der
wirtschaftskraft her darf man die kultur
und kreativbranche nicht vergessen wir
betragen 100 milliarden zum jährlichen
bruttosozialprodukt bei ja wir sind im
branchenvergleich nach der autoindustrie
die zweitgrößte branche und das darf
nicht vergessen werden und mein appell
richtet sich deshalb nicht an die
politik weil da habe ich keine hoffnung
mehr die sind leider im enddarm der
autolobby verschwunden
aber sie liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer diese 34 millionen die jedes
jahr ins theater gehen wenn sie sagen
ich will jetzt nicht ins theater das ist
mir zu unsicher
ich habe angst dann habe ich dafür ist
das verständnis für aber was jeder
machen kann von zu hause aus dem home
office ist eine email schreiben
und da würde ich sagen machen sie das
doch schreiben sie doch unsere den frau
bundeskanzlerin eine e-mail keine sonne
hass-mails wie sie wie die anderen sie
machen wo dann steht hier
fick dich ins knie und soja sondern eine
ganz nette mail einfach sagen frau
kanzlerin
bitte vergessen sie die kultur nicht und
ich gebe jetzt die e mailadresse durch
damit sie wissen wo sie hin schicken
können poststelle hat bundeskanzlerin
punkt.de mail.de 34 millionen mails und
sie wird die kultur nicht vergessen
wieso setzen sie sich für solo selbst ja
weil ich glaube dass es eine
berufsgruppe ist die nicht gesehen wird
in der gesellschafter sind wahnsinnig
viele weit über zwei millionen in dieser
gesellschaft die solo selbstständige
sind und ja auch nachweislich sehr viel
arbeiten viel mehr als normale
angestellte arbeiten und dafür aber auch
in geringeren lohn bekommen was muss man
sehen dass gleich raus und ich habe
jetzt gerade noch mal gelesen wir sind
glaube ich bei 8 eur 65
durchschnittlicher stundenlohn bei den
solo selbstständigen angekommen was ja
allen vorgaben des mindestlohnes
widerspricht aber es ist eine
berufsgruppe die aus durch
selbstausbeutung lebt oder von
selbstausbeutung und die vor allem durch
den lockdown glaube ich oder shutdown
oder auch durch die pandemie was wir
immer wie wir das immer nennen wollen
sehr stark betroffen ist also viele
können gar nicht mehr arbeiten obwohl
sie wollen sie haben ganz viele fakten
recherchiert ja zum thema solo
selbständige was hat sie am meisten
überrascht
ich glaube das was die meisten
überrascht hat ist wirklich erst mal die
wirtschaftskraft kreativbranche unter
solo selbstständigen das dass wir im
branchenvergleich nach der autoindustrie
der zweit wirtschaftsstärkste branche
überhaupt sind in deutschland der drei
prozent betragen der 3 das ist eine
unglaubliche bereiche also und und
veranstaltungsbranche heißt ja auch
nicht nur die kleinkunstbühnen theater
sondern auch große konzerte das ist
zählt ja auch alles dazu ja dann es gibt
ja über 1700 kleinkunstbühnen in diesem
land ich habe das jetzt im vorfeld zu
dieser sendung reserviert werden das ist
ja im deutschsprachigen raum 1700 er in
jedem zweiten kleinen kaff gibt's eine
kleinkunstbühne auf der was stattfindet
und und wenn wir uns schimpfen dass wir
eine eine kultur brauche eine kultur
land sind ein land das stolz ist auf
seine grad auch sehr feingliedrige
kultur die nicht nur den mainstream
bedient in der große konzerte
stattfinden
symphonie oder opa sondern wir sind
unglaublich breit aufgestellt in diesem
land und das geht gerade verloren also
ich glaube wir werden wenn das so
weitergeht im nächsten jahr diese
branche nicht wiedererkennen
das würde das mit deutschland machen ich
glaube was was nicht weiß was nicht
verkannt werden darf ist das natürlich
auch bühnen ein 1 1 1 1 ort
auseinandersetzung sind das ist ja nicht
nur ein entertainment faktor sondern da
finden gerne gerade in der demokratie
eine auseinandersetzung statt mit themen
ja in der dinge ein diskurs angestoßen
wird vielleicht dass man aus dem theater
rausgeht oder aus einem film oder von
einem buch ausschaut und merkt es gibt
einen tellerrand über den kann ich
hinweg blicken der gerade was wir jetzt
auch in dieser zeit und das denke ich
immer kabarettist deshalb auch so
wichtig für mich da selber nicht loben
aber wir haben so eine humorlose zeit
momentan wenn ich wenn ich die
demonstration sehe ja wie wenig humor
also wie viel auch die hartherzigkeit
sich breit gemacht hat in dieser
gesellschaft und etwas auf was diesen
kapitalismus diesem kapitalistischen
system etwas entgegensetzt nämlich zu
sagen der mensch ist mehr als die die
wertschöpfung dir selber hervorbringt
mehr als ein job das ist der mensch und
das dürfen wir nicht vergessen und wenn
uns das verloren geht ich glaube dann
sind wir bei lang bei diesen dystopien
die wir alle schon mal hatten dass der
mensch im prinzip ein teil eines
produktions h das ist ein kleines
rädchen in dem system indem er in dem in
der sich hinein fügte und das ist das wo
ginge ich immer gekämpft habe ich gesagt
habe das wollen wir nicht oder will ich
nicht was wirklich an übrig bleiben
diese gesellschaft wird veröden übrigens
auch die innenstädte
ich erinnere ich erinnere immer wieder
daran dass ja die theater nicht solitäre
sind in einer stadt herum das theater um
es in ganz oft restaurants cafés
entstanden es gibt leute die fahren mit
der straßenbahn mit dem taxi dahin ja es
gibt leute die kleiden sich feiern wenn
sie in die oper gehen ja das ist ja dass
da wird ja auch unglaublich viel
ausgegeben im bereich eines theaters
aus unserer gesprächen gewinnen wir den
eindruck
ständige im stich gelassen werden es
gibt jede menge bürokratischer hürden
die soforthilfe geht offenbar an der
lebenswirklichkeit der leute vorbei es
gibt keine direkten ansprechpartner und
so weiter wir wollen wissen ob das
wirklich so ist und fragen nach beim
deutschen institut für
wirtschaftsforschung in berlin professor
dr alexander kritikos ist der experte in
deutschland für solo selbständige in der
korona krise herr professor kritikers
was dürfen sie denn warum so wenig
unterstützung kommt für die solo
selbstständigen interessanterweise
glaubt ihr die bundesregierung dass sie
viel unterstützung gibt sie sagen eben
der grundsicherung und der soforthilfe
von den derzeitig überbrückungs dürfen
genug getan mehr müsste man nicht tun
weil unterschied eben zu den ab nicht
beschäftigten die solo selbstständigen
ja auch in keine versicherung einzahlen
so wie eben die abhängig beschäftigten
arbeitslosen versicherung einzahlen und
jetzt kurzarbeitergeld beziehen
das gibt es im parallel ich für die solo
selbst denkt deshalb sei dieses aus
sicht der bundesregierung das maximum
wasserwagen müsse und könne
kann man das an zahlen festmachen die
wir als solo selbständige mehr betroffen
von der korona krise als zum beispiel
abhängig beschäftigte nun anteilig
trifft es wohl selbst stecke sehr viel
häufiger als beschäftigte bei den
abhängig beschäftigten wissen wir dass
in der spitze rund 16 17 prozent
betroffen waren wir hatten einmal acht
millionen abhängig beschäftigten
kurzarbeit waren weil dem solo
selbstständige trifft es mehr als jeden
zweifel also hier sind 64 prozent aller
solo selbstständigen betroffen das sind
auf rund 2,2 millionen zusätzliche
gefällt neben über eine million solo
selbständige und insgesamt heißt das
eben das anteilig unter einer solo
selbstständigen eben sehr viel mehr
betroffen sind als bei abhängig
beschäftigt aber wenn das so weitergeht
dass die sohle selbständigen nicht von
der politik unterstützt werden
was hat das für folgen solange also wir
können ja nicht auf ewig durchhalten
dann im gegenteil ich schätze mal viele
haben schon aufgegeben wenn sie nicht
jetzt beginnt mit der abmilderung der
krise wieder normal arbeiten können aber
es gibt einige branchen den nach wie vor
ist nicht möglich zu arbeiten an der
insbesondere die veranstaltungsbranche
alles was drum herum ist also
gastgewerbe hotellerie kleine versionen
dort ist nach wie vor eben für viele ist
schwierig und wir wissen gleichzeitig
dass viele solo selbstständige nicht
viel mehr als 27 monate spielraum haben
um eine solche krise zu überstehen das
heißt viele der so nur selbstständigen
sind wahrscheinlich jetzt schon in der
situation dass wir sagen müssen sich
eben die selbstständigkeit auch wenn es
keine perspektive
das heißt wer zum herbst eine größere
zahl von geschäftsaufgaben oder einfach
von aufgaben dieser erwerbsform sehen
wenn wir also selbst stelle jetzt weil
ihn in den theatern in der kulturbranche
denken
dort müssen sie sich nur noch andere
jobs um suche gibt es in andere modelle
mit solo selbstständigen umzugehen etwa
in anderen europäischen ländern zum
beispiel es gibt eine anzahl von
europäischen ländern wie england
manndecker niederlande spanien auch
belgien die in einen anderen weg sie
erstatten dort er anteilig in
umsatzverlust und dieser umsatzverlust
wort dort vom finanzamt erstattet so
dass sie eben auch zielgenauer diese
hilfe bekommen können oder wichtigste
unterschied zu deutschland ist was diese
ersten dort auch verwendet werden
könnten lebensunterhalt zu bestreiten
kann es sein dass die art und weise wie
wir in deutschland mit solo selbständige
umgehen auch ein ergebnis des
föderalismus ist dass es einfach in
anderen ländern deshalb auch anders sein
kann was zentraler dann auch geregelt
wird wenn ich denke es ist tatsächlich
in deutschland erstmal eine entscheidung
der bundesregierung gewesen
sozusagen auf bundesebene keine apfels
gewähren die auch für den
lebensunterhalt zugelassen sind das land
baden württemberg ist er ausgeschert und
hat gesagt wir halten uns nicht an diese
vorgabe und ich schätze mal auch dass da
noch nicht das letzte wort gesprochen es
gewaltig auch zulässig
an dieser stelle müssen wir eigentlich
die politiker zu wort kommen
aber wir haben uns dagegen entschieden
es macht einfach keinen sinn
wir haben telefoniert und telefoniert
bund und länder schieben sich
gegenseitig den schwarzen peter zu die
länder haben sich untereinander nicht
koordiniert und jeder macht und sagt was
anderes
also als im märz der lockdown anfängen
da hatten wir gerade eine premiere
hinter uns also eine echte aufwendiges
viel text gedöns und wir könnten uns
genau fünf mitspielen das heißt
inzwischen habe ich den text natürlich
komplett vergessen alles noch mal neu
lernen und dann habe ich die ersten zwei
wochen habe ich es so als als urlaubs
geschenkt nehmen können
was ich aber dann allerspätestens
geändert hat als ich also ich werde ich
werde schon sehr beeindruckt von bildern
und als ich die bilder aus italien
gesehen habe wie die militärfahrzeuge
die toten von der stadt bringen
das war für mich so der punkt es ist ja
unangenehm wurde und dann kam die lange
zeit des nichts tun können es außer auf
sich aufpassen auf andere aufpassen sich
die nachrichten fressen womit ich auch
irgendwann natürlich aufgehört habe was
weil es ein jahr wahnsinnig macht und
dann natürlich die große frage wofür bin
ich jetzt gut ich kann nur das was ich
die ganzen jahre gemacht habe und das
war es gab ja quasi ein berufsverbot
ganz abgesehen von geld verbrennt
verdient verbot dann kommt diese systeme
irrelevanz die einem so ein bisschen die
seele zerfrisst weil weil man hat den
eindruck es läuft darauf hinaus dass es
einen irgendwann einfach nicht mehr gibt
weil weil du eben nicht arbeiten kannst
was macht kronor mit den solo
selbstständigen emotional
ich kann das nicht ich kann ich habe mit
vielen kolleginnen darüber telefoniert
in der zeit oder auch gesprochen
sz ihr den boden unter den füßen weg
weil du weil du systemrelevant bist du
nimmst zu erkennen ist dass die
unterstützung gar nicht kommt oder nur
tröpfchenweise oder in lächerlichen
beträgen
du nimmst erkennen ist dass du dich
nicht äußern kannst also ist das was du
kannst wird gerade nicht erlaubt nicht
verlangt ist nicht machbar also fragst
du dich wofür bist du eigentlich gut
das was kannst du dieser gesellschaft
geben und in diesen monaten wenig bis
gar nichts und und all die pläne also
auch andere so was weiß ich
architekten oder die ganzen techniker
und technikerinnen die um einen rum
gewuselt haben und so die alle deren
hohes handwerkliches können gerade brach
lag ich glaube dass da franz dein
selbstbewusstsein an den rändern aus
ja klar
kreativität kreativität funktioniert vor
allen dingen im dialog wenn der nicht
mehr da ist dann fragst du dich
wofür soll ich schreiben für welche
situation für welche menschen verwandeln
und was ist dann relevant ich bin ja
sehr verbandelt mit einem privat theater
in oberhausen
was aufgrund seiner jenny subventioniert
zu werden also immer die ausbeuterische
freie kultur zu praktizieren
selbstausbeutung was durch jedes raster
gefallen ist was diese diese
unterstützung was das endet in einem
privatkredit die frage ist können wir
ihn jemals zurückzahlen
es ist das ist so es fühlt sich so
geplant an sodass man daher diese diese
ganze riesen solo selbstständige
abteilung dass man sich dass es
niemanden gibt bei diesen ganzen
bürokraten die sich die sich wirklich
damit auseinandersetzen und das größte
problem was sie genannt haben ist dass
es von vom bundesebene nicht runter sagt
in die in die landes- und dann in die
städte ebene gema zu deinem zuständigen
arbeitsamt für hartz4 antragen
also die auftragsbücher waren voll bis
februar 2020 dann ging das von 100 auf
null in paar sekunden also keine
aufträge keine anfragen es kam gar
nichts mehr rein
aber wie kann das sein wir haben ja
gelernt durch corona dass die
digitalisierung einen sehr hohen
stellenwert hat und alle brauchen die
klasse halten dass man dann dass
ausgerechnet it-berater dann keine jobs
mehr bekommen das sollte man meinen das
habe ich auch gedacht weil projekte
laufen weiter die edv systeme müssen
entwickelt werden
aber meine auftraggeber haben ganz
knallhart gesagt wir müssen das erstmal
stoppen und wir warten ab wie sich die
lage mit krone entwickelt was heißt das
für sie konkret für auswirkungen wie hat
sich das für sie auch angefühlt ich
hatte jetzt sieben monate keinen auftrag
ich habe ungefähr 5000 bewerbung
geschrieben weil mir blieb ja nichts
anderes übrig war ich wollte auch den
kopf im sand stecken aber wenn ich auf
der einen seite spüre aha du hast 1500
euro mindestens lebenshaltungskosten mit
krank für sich und alle hast aber nichts
gegessen und du christ vom staat 300
dann geht irgendwann einem die luft aus
und deshalb habe ich natürlich dann
irgendwann nach einer anfänglichen
ruhephase noch keiner wusste was mit
corona ist meine bemühungen verstärkt um
ihren auftrag zu bekommen und das ist
gott sei dank jetzt belohnt worden
das heißt der der leidensdruck ist jetzt
so ein bisschen weg und aber es
hinterlässt spuren weil ich mich einfach
und viele andere solo selbstständige
auch von der regierung komplett im stich
gelassen fühlen
ja mein geschäft ist von einer minute
zur anderen auf null runtergefahren
ich hatte stornierungen bzw
verschiebungen die unternehmen die bei
mir gebucht hatten für märz haben
erstmal auf april oder mai verschoben
manche haben sofort ihre aufträge erst
mal runtergefahren und ja auch schon
angedeutet dass so schnell nichts kommen
würde weil auch sie jetzt erstmal mit
dieser neuen situation umgehen müssen
und das macht mit mir natürlich eine
unsicherheit und auch eine ja manchmal
wie soll ich sagen die verzweiflung
allerdings bin ich jetzt auch jemand der
sich auch gut stabilisieren kann mit mit
freunden mit nebenbeschäftigungen also
im sinne von den schrebergarten und ja
also ich mach was so im sinne der
resilienz der also selbstwirksamkeit ich
versuche neue konzepte aufzulegen mit
kollegen viel zu machen so dass wir in
thun bleiben und nicht komplett in der
sinnlosigkeit oder in der
beschäftigungslosigkeit zurückfahren
oder untergehen
natürlich hätte ich gerne mehr
unterstützung von von offizieller seite
wenn ich dann sehe wie die gelder in
unternehmen gepumpt werden wie viele
leute kurzarbeitergeld erhöht bekommen
was ich den wirklich gerne aber dann
empfehle ich mich als selbstständige
schon sehr im stich gelassen
ein appell an die politik wäre für mich
ja sehen sie mich eher als kunden oder
als bürger der die letzten 14 jahre
erhebliche steuern bezahlt hat ich
konnte mich gut finanzieren
ich konnte gute dem staat auch zur seite
stehen ich machen sinnvollen job
ich werde mich einfach gerne mehr sehen
als als unterstützenswert
immerhin es gibt eine
interessenvertretung und zwar den
verband der gründer und selbstständigen
in deutschland
wenn wir uns nun liegt das ganze jahr im
verantwortungsbereich des
bundeswirtschaftsministers peter
altmaier haben sie mit ihm gesprochen
ganz am anfang der krise waren hier
eingeladen und ich hatte die chance
herren altmaier und auch ein teil
unserer forderungen zu präsentieren
wir müssen unseren einfluss wirklich
sehr sehr mühsam erkämpfen bei
ministerien sind gewöhnt mit den
gewerkschaften sie sprechen auf der
einen seite und mit den arbeitgeber denn
die haben in unserem lande das habe ich
gelernt sehr sehr gemacht das ist
natürlich die lobby der angestellten
arbeite große industrieunternehmen der
autor wie werden wir kleinen
selbstständigen ohne angestellte wir
sind ja weder arbeitnehmer noch
arbeitgeber also wir haben diese lobby
nicht wir müssen quasi durch die
instanzen einen barsch machen damit wir
auch berücksichtigt werden
da sind wir dabei aber offensichtlich
haben wir hier in wirtschaften ist ja
noch einen langen weg vor uns
wenn du den meisten solo selbstständigen
nicht geholfen wird zumindest dann nicht
wenn sie keine betriebskosten verbuchen
können was wird das bedeuten für die
wirtschaft in deutschland
ich denke es geht viel an flexibilität
verloren wenn er weniger junge
selbstständige haben denn es ohne frage
werden viele aufgeben müssen das sieht
ja jeder von uns wenn er die
einkaufsstraße sagen wie das mit der
vielfalt verloren gehen in den städten
ist vielfalt verloren gehen in der
kulturszene
es wird der wettbewerb abnehmen und
natürlich sind die betroffenen
verbittert das sind leute die über viele
jahre steuern bezahlt haben wie sich als
stützen der gesellschaft ziehen und
denen einfach nicht geholfen wird in
dieser schwierigen situation das ist die
auf hartz 4 verwiesen werden das ist
ganz ganz bitter und sorgt für große
enttäuschung und und entfremdung
entfremdung auch von der politik
das macht mir sorgen und sorgen macht
mir auch dass natürlich die bereitschaft
künftig setzen unternehmen zu gründen
abnehmen wird die selbstständigen werden
ihren kindern nicht mehr zur
selbstständigkeit raten sie werden sagen
und in deutschland was zu gelten da
musst du beamter werden oder
angestellter dann hast du große
sicherheit als selbstständiger bis zur
erwerbstätiger dritter klasse
ich hörte wir deutschen haben einen
großen teil unserer lebensfreude
verloren
das ist eine sehr problematische
geschichte wird leiden irgendwann
einander einer kollektiven depression
und das dürfen wir nicht machen wir
müssen auch mal den fernseher
ausschalten nicht jede talkshow angucken
wir müssen auch mal den computer aus
lassen und nicht jeden tag irgendwelche
infektionszahlen lesen wir müssen auch
mal loslassen können und deswegen habe
ich diese strophe geschrieben
wenn es im fernsehen plötzlich keine
anderen meldungen mehr gibt wenn man im
supermarkt über nichts anderes mehr
redet wenn du zu allen abstand hält den
alten vater nicht mehr siehst wenn du
hast angst vor einem virus fast verblüht
ist dann denkt doch nicht an heute was
machst du in einem jahr
du bist am meer und dieser virus ist
einfach nicht mehr da lass dich selbst
einmal in ruhe sie nach vorne ohne angst
jetzt wird es wirklich einmal zeit erst
um loslassen kann loslassen ist auch ein
lied gegen die angst ferner die angst
muss man mal loslassen wenn wir
natürlich wollen wir vorsichtig sein und
natürlich auch gerade für die anderen ja
also der mund nasen schutz ist ja nicht
nur für mich auch für mich aber vor
allen dingen auch wenn ich mich
angesteckt haben sollte
die anderen so ich erwarte von deutschen
einfach diesen gewissen grund
solidarität die mehrheit bei vielen
leuten so fehlt und loslassen heißt aber
sich von der angst auch mal irgendwann
entfernt also ist los lassen eine
botschaft an die bevölkerung ja aber
auch an die solo selbstständigen war ja
die sind ja auch wenn man jetzt will man
jetzt wenn man jetzt in wie solo
selbständige existenz in der existenz
bedroht ist dann wird loslassen verdammt
schwer aber wenn wenn die anderen nicht
wieder ins theater gehen die die
bevölkerung nicht wieder in kultur will
dann wird es denen noch schlechter geht
was wäre deutschland ohne die kultur die
wir jetzt haben
was war es das heißt es mund das bunte
wie die ideen die schräg der querdenker
ich war wie querdenker sind nicht die
die sich so nennen auf den bei den demo
sondern die querdenker sind die die auf
böden stehen und ihre ideen präsentieren
und leute zum denken anregen
ich sitze oft mit dem theater und denke
mir du hast nicht recht kollege aber ich
weiß was er will hat sich die korona
pandemie bei ihnen ausgewirkt haben die
veranstaltung absagen müssen
ja ja fast alle also wir hätten in
diesem jahr hatten die 100 konzerte 100
kabarett abende geplant und es bleiben
glaube ich so 12 also 90 prozent fallen
weg und die die jetzt stattfindende
natürlich
rohner sitzplan das heißt es ist ein
land wieder frei
das ist wieder eine oder zwei will sie
zu einem haushalt kommen und das ist der
eine punkt aber sind gibt es auch noch
leute die hatten ursprünglich karten
gekauft kommen aber nicht weil sie angst
haben
trotzdem sind sicher gut situiert im
geschäft ein erfolgreicher
kulturschaffende warum engagieren sie
sich für solo selbstständige wie alle
anderen das ist alle anderen ein anderer
geht es nicht so mein technischer leiter
der ist auch solo selbständige und er
hat jetzt das ein halbes jahr
durchgestanden und jetzt ist er fertig
mehr geht nicht und das geht der halten
branche so politiker müssen wir abwägen
zwischen vielen verschiedenen dingen in
diesem falle einem gefährlichen virus
der uns oder ganz viele von uns zu töten
kann aber auch dem wirtschaftlichen
fortbestand und der wirtschaftlichen
existenz vieler millionen menschen ja
was raten sie der politik und
assistenten im falle der kultur ist es
eben nicht nur die wirtschaftliche seite
der wirtschaftsminister professor
pinkwart der also westfälische
wirtschaftsminister der hat gesagt er
sieht nicht dass man einzelne braun
einzelnen branchen helfen soll dass die
werden dann lieber durch
überbrückungsgeld am leben halten was
natürlich schon extrem arrogant ist aber
ich mir vorstelle da werden milliarden
in die lufthansa gepumpt da werden wir
drei prozent
die mehrwertsteuer gesenkt damit der
einzelhandel wieder wieder brummt da
werden
als die ersten läden geöffnet wurden bis
800 quadratmetern hieß es alle läden bis
800 quadratmeter plus möbelhäuser
zusammenrufen möbelhäuser ich kann sie
sagen gibt so viele so das heißt wenn
ich so viele einzelne branchen
bevorteilen dann bei der
veranstaltungswirtschaft sage ich halte
es für falsch einzelne branchen zu das
ist ja schon franke züge also alles rund
um mich herum vergessen und einfach
irgendwas erzählen
also es ist so dass diese
veranstaltungswirtschaft und die
kulturelle seite wird als einzelne
branche nicht geholfen wird und dass ist
das ist kanada ist in der schweiz ist es
so dass man sagt die künstler die jetzt
nicht arbeiten können die kriegen
einfach mal statt 80 prozent ihres
gehaltes vom letzten mal
im letzten jahr es sei denn sie haben eh
genug also ich würde wahrscheinlich
nicht so viel klingen aber
aber wie schon gesagt es geht nicht um
mich aber normalerweise ein normaler
auftreten der künstler krieg vom staat
hat die aktiv sind
das muss nicht irgendwelchen
wirtschaftsministerium an das muss das
finanzamt an das finanzamt weiß ganz
genau was derjenige verdient hat und die
wissen auch ganz genau der hat genug wer
braucht nicht so wenn die finanzämter
das machen würden und würden einfach
sagen kommen zwei drittel kriegst du
erst mal in diesem jahr
und wenn du hinterher mehr geld verdient
als im gesamten rest wieder zurück das
wäre alles und das wäre auch alles an
bürokratie notwendig wäre das schaffen
unsere finanzämter
ich halte ja sehr sehr viel von
finanzämtern die schaffen das bequem
ich finde es einfach unfassbar wie die
uns gegen die wand fahren lassen und
zwar sehenden auges da braucht mir
keiner zu erzählen die wüssten das nicht
wie soll man das denn nicht wissen wie
sind eigentlich die drei milliarden
rübergekommen zur lufthansa wir haben
die das geschafft wussten die auch zu
irgendeinem arbeitsamt wie ist die
bürgschaft für schalke bb ist das geld
woanders hin gekommen sind so viele
gelder dafür so viele branchen warum ist
für die solo selbständige nichts daher
warum haben die keine lobby
ich möchte dass ein deutscher
wirtschaftsminister den leuten sagt
wisst ihr was wir haben jetzt lange
genug zu hause gesessen und trübsal
geblasen
geht mal wieder raus amüsiert euch das
hätte ich gerne die leute sollen
natürlich ihrem ihren mund nasenschutz
dabei andere trotzdem raus gehen
wir stehen hier übrigens nicht nur für
uns selber wir stehen hier für zwei
millionen solo selbständige in
deutschland was die nicht im stich
[Musik]